[Musik]
am anfang hatten wir doch die hoffnung
dass man doch wie gut denn haben und die
stellt genommen
dann haben wir gesehen ab die rebellen
haben sie sich haben sie sich entwickelt
in dem sie verbrechen begangen habe also
jugoslawien tribunal ist eine
erfolgsgeschichte sicher 161 hohen
politischen und militärischen
verantwortlichen sind vor gericht
gekommen und verurteilt worden war ein
großer erfolg für die gerechtigkeit für
die opfer
das gleiche sollte brasilien erscheinen
nicht dass sicherheitsrat endlich
endlich eine resolution nimmt dass man
an dass man justiz machen kann auch
wissen darum wäre er werde die zeit dass
man dass man ein internationales
gerichtshof hat und etwas unternimmt
aber leider geschieht wie sieht's noch
nichts
ich denke mir
die arbeiten die ein gericht so haben
würde ist unglaublich unglaublich
wir sind noch nicht so weit
die kommission hat eine kleine aber
anfangs arbeit gemacht aber das gibt es
noch vieles zu tun damit war zu den
prozessen kommt was mir wehtut sind
diese kinder die die in den spitälern
sind und und dandy getötet werden und
verwundet sind also diese kinder sind
diese kleine kinder werden dann größer
und das ist eine eine dramatisierte
jugend und das ist unglaublich
[Musik]